The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
For this half of the course,
we talked about chemical
equilibrium, acid-base.
We talked oxidation-reduction.
We talked about shapes of
molecules.
We talked about this VSEPR
theory.
We talked about transition
metals and kinetics,
which we just ended on Monday.
All of these things represent
the basic principles of how
enzymes work.
Enzymes work by acid-base
catalysis.
They catalyze oxidation
reduction reactions.
And so if we want to understand
biochemistry,
you need to understand these
basic principles of chemistry.
That is how I got into
chemistry in the first place,
was this connection.
And, as I mentioned last time,
inhibition of enzymes is an
important area.
And we need to understand how
the enzymes work if we want to
inhibit them.
Well, why do we want to inhibit
them?
Well, inhibition of enzymes is
used in the treatment of a lot
of different conditions.
Headaches.
This time of year,
a lot of us walk around
carrying a bottle.
Sometimes the small size isn't
going to really quite do it.
We might get a little larger.
Here is ibuprofen.
There are a number of headaches
that occur around now.
And headaches are treated by
inhibiting an enzyme.
Someone has designed an
inhibitor for an enzyme,
and the enzymes are called
prostaglandin synthases or
cyclooxygenases.
And these materials,
like aspirin and stuff,
bind to the enzyme and inhibit
them.
And, to get good inhibitors,
we need to know how the enzyme
works.
And so some of you have heard a
lot of news recently about
Vioxx.
That was a drug that was
designed to target the enzymes.
They were very proud of
themselves for trying to make
the drug very specific to a
particular type of
cylcooxygenase enzymes that
would only inhibit the class two
and not one.
And it turns out that was a
great idea, except that it
turned out to be dangerous.
We will see how that plays out.
But, all of that,
they are targeting enzymes.
Arthritis.
A lot of drugs to treat cancer
are inhibiting enzymes.
I mentioned HIV,
that there are inhibitors
against HIV protease,
which is an enzyme.
And so the people have designed
inhibitors against that enzyme.
Designing inhibitors against
enzymes is a big part of the
pharmaceutical industry.
And, to really have a good
inhibitor, a good pharmaceutical
product, you need to know a lot
about how the enzyme works and
also something about how the
cell works, so that you can make
a good product.
And this is big money.
Understanding these basic
principles, then,
allows you to understand how
enzymes work.
I am going to take one enzyme,
and I am going to tell you
about the enzyme.
I am going to tell you about
how this enzyme works to do its
reaction.
And I am going to use,
in telling you about the
enzyme, all of these things.
All of these different topics
you need to know to understand
this one enzyme.
And, if you understand these
different topics,
you will, in fact,
be able to understand how this
enzyme works.
The enzyme, it shouldn't
surprise you,
is vitamin B12 dependent,
my favorite vitamin.
And it is called methionine
synthase.
I have mentioned this a little
bit in the course of this
semester, and we are going to go
back over some of these things
as a review.
This is going to serve as a
review of the different topics
that we have covered,
at the same time showing how
these basic principles apply to
other fields in chemistry and
biology.
We will start at the back.
We will start with kinetics.
That is easy.
Methionine synthase is an
enzyme, and enzymes are
catalysts.
Catalysts speed up reactions,
make them go faster.
And the speed of reactions is
what kinetics is.
Here is the reaction that
methionine synthase catalyzes.
It converts an amino acid
called homocysteine into another
amino acid called methionine.
And it takes one form of folic
acid, which is another B
vitamin, and converts it to
another form of folic acid.
And this reaction is very
important in your body.
It is important for the proper
formation and maintenance of
your spinal cord.
And women who are pregnant need
to take lots of folic acid to
make sure that they have enough
for this reaction to go,
so the baby is born with a
properly formed brain and spinal
column.
Inhibition is connected with
neural tube defects.
Homocysteine is linked with
heart disease.
You want to make sure this
enzyme is working really well.
You will have too much
homocysteine,
and that is a big indicator of
problems with heart disease.
Also, you need this
tetrahydrofolate,
this one form of folic acid,
for DNA biosynthesis.
Some people have thought about
inhibiting this enzyme to
prevent this reaction,
and that would lead to stopping
cancer cells from growing.
Of course, if they do that,
they might cause people,
then, to have heart problems.
There are definitely balances,
and that is why the
pharmaceutical industry often
gets in trouble,
because you solve one problem
and then create another one.
You really need to know a lot
about how the system works as a
whole to be able to design good
inhibitors.
So, this is a really important
reaction.
For this reaction to go in the
body, you need a catalyst,
you need this enzyme.
What do catalysts do?
This is review of what we
talked about Monday.
Catalysts act by lowering the
activation energy barrier,
lowering EA,
the activation energy barrier
for the forward reaction and
also for the reverse reaction.
They do not change the overall
thermodynamics,
they do not change delta G,
they do not change the
equilibrium constant,
but they do speed up the
reaction by lowering this
barrier.
There is a much higher barrier
without the catalyst,
lower barrier,
it stabilizes.
Another way to think about it
is it stabilizes the activated
state or the transition state.
Catalysts are not in the
overall equation,
they are not consumed in the
reaction, they are just added to
make the reaction go faster.
That is a catalyst.
Enzymes are the catalyst of
life.
Transition metals.
We are moving backwards through
the semester,
transition metals.
This one, lots of transmission
metals.
It uses vitamin B12,
which has cobalt,
and it uses zinc.
Here is the methyl form of
vitamin B12, also called
methylcobalamin,
and it has a corn ring.
A corn ring contributes four
nitrogen ligands to the central
cobalt, so it is a tetradentate
ligand.
And that tetradentate ligand
coordinates the cobalt.
It is a chelate.
And so we can review what the
chelate effect is.
A chelating ligand has multiple
points of attachment to the
particular metal.
And they are unusually stable.
Why are chelates unusually
stable?
What factor is it that causes
that unusual stability?
It is entropy.
It is entropic effects,
because usually you are
replacing four bound waters,
in this case,
with one ligand.
You are putting one thing on
and releasing four.
And it is easier for four
things to be disordered than for
one thing to be disordered.
That gives you a favorable
entropic effect.
The chelate effect has to do
with entropy.
Now let's consider the zinc.
It also needs zinc for this to
work.
Zinc plus two,
what would be the d-count?
How many d electrons are you
going to have?
For that, we would go to the
Periodic Table,
find zinc and see which group
it is in.
It is 12.
The oxidation number is 2.
We are at 12 minus 2 or a d ten
state.
What would you guess would be
the color of this zinc site?
Colorless.
And that is because you are not
going to be able to have any
d-to-d transitions because you
have ten electrons,
everything is full.
There are five orbitals and
they all have two electrons
each, so it is completely full.
You would have a colorless
system.
Now, people did not realize
methionine synthase was a zinc
enzyme for a long time.
Vitamin B12 has a beautiful red
color, and zinc had no color.
They knew it was a
B12-dependent enzyme,
but people were studying this
enzyme for years and years and
years before they realized that
zinc was bound to the protein
because it has no color.
What about VSEPR?
VSEPR allows you to predict or
rationalize shapes of molecules
based on a simple idea of
repulsion.
That lone pairs want to fill up
space and move the bound atoms
away.
That the structure is designed
such that there is minimal
repulsion between bound
electrons or electrons in
orbitals.
If we consider this,
then, if we look at the steric
number for the whole center
around the cobalt.
Again, there is this
tetradentate corn ring system,
and there is one ligand above
and one ligand below.
And so what does that give for
our steric number?
Six.
We have four in the equatorial
positions and two in the axial
positions.
What formula would this be?
What is first?
A, then X, then six.
We have a central atom A and we
have six things around it.
And what would be the geometry
of something that has six things
around it?
Octahedral.
And here we have our octahedral
system.
If I hold it like this,
the equatorial positions are
filled with the corn ring,
have a methyl group on top.
And we have another ligand on
the bottom.
What are the angles for
octahedral?
90, thank you.
All right.
The zinc site,
I will tell you a little bit
about the zinc site.
Three ligands were identified
to zinc.
And so geometry is going to
have X equals three.
If we don't know what the
ligands are, we might not know
about lone pairs.
But if you have three things
bound, what is the most common
geometry if three things are
bound?
Trigonal planar is pretty
common with three things bound,
so that might be a good guess.
And so it might look something
like this.
And what would be the angles,
if that was the correct
geometry?
Right, 120.
Okay.
We know something about it from
VSEPR.
All right.
Oxidation-reduction.
This enzyme catalyzes an
oxidation-reduction reaction.
Here is the cycle of turnover
for this enzyme.
We have a lot of different
reactions going on in this
enzyme.
Here is an abbreviation for the
cobalamin cofactor.
We just have the cobalt and its
oxidation number of one,
here.
Sometimes, instead of going
around in this primary turnover,
its normal sort of cycle,
where it is reacting with the
folic acid and reacting with the
homocysteine.
Instead, sometimes an electron
is lost.
And, for it to kind of come
back into the catalytic cycle,
the enzyme needs to be
activated.
And so it becomes Co-two state.
It loses an electron and
becomes oxidized.
And then you have to re-reduce
it and you have to methylate it
to go back into this form.
A methyl is just a carbon with
three hydrogens.
The methyl group comes from
this compound called S-adenosyl
methionine, and it gets an
electron for the reduction from
flavodoxin.
If we look at this
oxidation-reduction,
and we talked about this a big
earlier, too,
but it is a really nice review
for oxidation-reduction.
We have a standard potential
for vitamin B12 of minus 0.526
volts and a standard potential
for flavodoxin of minus 0.23
volts.
Which of these is a better
reducing agent?
B12 is a better reducing agent.
A large negative reduction
potential means that the reduced
species is very reducing.
If it is a good reducing agent,
it likes to reduce other things
and be oxidized itself,
so B12 has a low negative
number.
If we do the math here and
calculate a delta E for the
cell, and, again,
the same equations can apply,
if you are talking about a
battery or you are talking about
a biological process.
We have the standard reduction
potential for the reaction that
is a reduction,
and the standard reduction
potential for the reaction that
is acting as the oxidation.
And, in this biological case,
flavodoxin is reducing vitamin
B12.
Flavodoxin is getting oxidized
and B12 is getting reduced.
And, if we put in the numbers,
we find that delta E is minus
0.296.
Is that going to be a
spontaneous reaction?
No, it won't be a spontaneous
reaction.
Because if this is negative,
if delta E is negative,
then delta G is going to be
positive.
And if delta G is positive,
then it is not spontaneous.
And we did this math before,
but just as a review,
you can calculate delta G if
you know the delta E.
It is just minus the number of
electrons involved times Faraday
constant times your delta E,
your change in the cell
potential.
That would be minus one,
it is a one electron reduction,
times Faraday's constant,
times the cell potential we
calculated.
And we get positive 28.6
kilojoules per mole.
That is not spontaneous.
But, as I mentioned,
the cells come up with a way to
do this.
It has to do this reaction,
or none of us would be alive.
This is an important reaction
for us.
The way that it does that is it
couples it with another
reaction.
So, at the same time the
reduction is happening,
you are cleaving that a
S-adenosyl methionine.
It is giving up the methyl
group, which is important for
the reaction.
But also, this is very
favorable, minus 37.6 kilojoules
per mole.
That allows the reaction to go.
That sort of pumps in the
energy that is needed for this
unfavorable oxidation-reduction
reaction to occur.
Cells that require energy to
catalyze non-spontaneous
reactions are called what?
Right, electrolytic.
And if it is a spontaneous
reaction, it is what?
Galvanic, right.
Here, in this one example,
we talk about the connection
between thermodynamics and
oxidation-reduction,
and we talk about oxidizing
agents and reducing agents.
All right.
The enzyme does an
oxidation-reduction.
It is a catalyst,
it speeds up the reaction,
it has two transition metals in
it and it uses acid-base
catalysis as well.
Let's talk about acid-base.
There is an acid-base reaction.
There is catalysis by a Lewis
acid in this part of the
reaction, the reaction with
homocysteine,
the conversion to methionine.
Let's talk about this.
The B12 is going to give up
this methyl group,
two homocysteine,
to make methionine.
It turns out that only the
deprotonated homocysteine is
reactive.
Here is homocysteine.
It is an amino acid.
This is proteinated.
The sulfur down here has a
proton.
This is deproteinated
homocysteine.
The sulfur here has no proton.
It has a negative charge.
And only this homocysteine here
that is deprotonated with the
sulfur with the negative charge
can be methylated.
The reaction catalyzed
transfers this methyl group,
this CH three group and
puts it on the sulfur,
and that makes the amino acid
methionine.
But if there is a proton there,
the methyl transfer does not
happen.
It has to be deprotonated.
At physiological pH,
we need to ask the question,
how much homocysteine is
deprotonated?
Remember, our body is buffered.
It is all around the same pH.
We want to know at this pH,
how much of the homocysteine is
in the deprotonated form and how
much of the homocysteine is in
the protonated form?
What do we need to know,
what value do we need to know
to be able to answer,
at a particular pH,
how much HA you have and how
much A minus you have?
What do we need to know?
We need to know the pKa.
Question.
What is the pKA?
Here, it is ten.
That is a big number.
If we know the physiological
pH, we know the pKA,
what equation can we use to
find the ratio of HA to
A minus?
Henderson-Hasselbach.
We can do the math.
Physiological pH is around 7.4.
The pKa is ten.
What is the ratio of protonated
to deprotonated,
the ratio of this protonated
homocysteine to the
deprotonated?
It turns out to be 400
protonated for every one
deprotonated.
Well, that is bad news for us
because it needs to be
deprotonated to be reactive.
At physiological pH,
then, it is protonated and
nonreactive.
Here the enzyme has to come in.
Enzymes catalyze reactions.
The enzyme needs to get
involved and make this reaction
happen.
Again, this is unfavorable
without the enzyme.
Let's think a little bit about
pH and pKa for a minute.
Let's review some acid-base
titration issues.
This is not in your handout,
I don't think,
it has been there before,
but let's just take a look at
it.
You should remember what these
titration curves look like.
Remember, at the half
equivalence point,
pH equals pKa.
And that happens because at the
half equivalence point,
half of the acid has been
converted to the conjugate base.
These are equal quantities.
And so they will cancel out in
the Henderson-Hasselbach and
this will be true.
You have equal amounts.
If you are at a pH that is
below the half equivalence
point, you will be more
protonated.
If you are at a pH that is
above the half equivalence
point, you will be more
deprotonated.
We have not maybe discussed
this in these terms,
but that is how you can think
about this problem.
Now, let's go back to
methionine synthase,
and this is in your handout.
At the half equivalence point
in a titration,
or when the pH equals the pKA,
half of your material is
protonated, half of your
material is deprotonated.
If your pH is below that pKa,
you are more protonated.
If you are a little bit below,
you still have some
deprotonated.
If you are very far below,
it is all protonated.
Going the other direction,
if you are at pH above the pKa,
you have mostly deprotonated,
maybe a little protonated.
And when you get far away,
it is all deprotonated.
Now we can put in what we know
about homocysteine.
The pKa is ten,
and we are at pH 7.4,
so we are quite a bit below the
pKa.
And we calculated that at that
pH with this pKa,
we would have 400 protonated to
every one deprotonated.
I am not going to write out 400
of these to be protonated for
every one deprotonated,
but we are mostly protonated.
All right.
That is the problem,
because we don't want to be
protonated.
We want to be deprotonated for
the enzyme to work.
What does the enzyme do?
Well, part of how the enzyme
catalyzes the reaction is that
it lowers the pKa of the
homocysteine.
Instead of ten,
which is what the pKa is with
free homocysteine,
the pKa now,
when homocysteine is bound to
the enzyme, is six.
That is a pretty substantial
drop.
The pKa is substantially
lowered.
Now let's go and look at what
that does for us in terms of the
reaction that is catalyzed.
All right.
What is happening here is the
zinc.
Here comes the zinc.
The zinc is acting as a Lewis
acid, and it is coordinating,
binding that homocysteine.
And that interaction between
the zinc and the sulfur of the
homocysteine lowers the pKa of
the homocysteine from ten to
six.
That is why this protein has to
have the zinc to act as the
Lewis acid.
We can go back to
Henderson-Hasselbach and plug in
our new values.
We are still at physiological
pH, 7.4.
But now, the pKa is 6.
And so our ratio then,
of protonated to deprotonated,
instead of 400 to one,
is now one to 25.
There is more deprotonated
homocysteine when it is bound to
the enzyme at this physiological
pH because the pKa is lower.
And if we look at that in terms
of this again --
-- Here is the pKa.
The protonated is equal to
deprotonated,
and our pKa now is six for the
bound homocysteine.
And now the pH,
the physiological pH is above
the pKa.
It is at 7.4.
And, above the pKa,
there is more deprotonated,
25 deprotonated to one
proteinated.
Now we are in good shape.
You need the deprotonated for
it to be reactive.
Most of it is deprotonated.
The enzyme can go.
The enzyme uses this Lewis acid
catalysis to drive this reaction
forward in the direction that
you want.
It is all about adjusting.
Enzymes can work by adjusting
pKa's.
All right.
Chemical equilibrium,
the first thing we started with
in the second half of the
semester.
What is true about methionine
synthase is that it exists in
multiple conformations.
This enzyme can have multiple
states.
And these conformations are in
equilibrium with each other.
Lots of things can be in
equilibrium, including enzymes.
And an equilibrium is a dynamic
process.
What is happening?
Well, let's look at why this
enzyme would need multiple
states.
Well, it needs to react with
homocysteine,
it needs to react with the
folic acid, and it needs to
react with the S-adenosyl
methionine and flavodoxin to do
this reaction over here.
If we look at the structure of
the enzyme, the vitamin B12 is
in green, the methyl group that
is going to be transferred is in
red, and all this yellow and
white is more protein.
Homocysteine,
when it is deprotonated,
needs to come in here and
accept that methyl group.
Folic acid needs to come in
here and donate the methyl
group.
And also S-adenosyl methionine,
in the activation reaction,
needs to methylate at the same
time the electron is added to
the system.
The enzyme needs to position
all of these guys up here.
And, if you look at the
structure, there is no room for
anything to fit into the
structure.
Nothing can kind of go over.
You can just barely see the
methyl group.
But these guys are kind of big
and are not going to fit in
here.
Because in this one
conformation of the enzyme,
they do not fit.
The answer has to be that the
enzyme moves,
it changes shape during the
reaction.
And this is something that had
been known for enzymes,
that they did this for quite
some time, but my father told
all our neighbors that his
daughter had discovered that
enzymes change shape.
[LAUGHTER] But,
since none of our neighbors
knew anything about
biochemistry,
even what an enzyme was,
I think that that was just
fine.
All right.
So this needs to change shape.
This is a picture of the
structure.
Here is the B12.
The red is the methyl group
again.
This whole region needs to move
to make room for those reactions
to happen.
There has got to be a number of
different states of this
protein.
Here is a little cartoon.
In orange is where the B12
binds to the protein.
The B12 is in red.
This region above we call the
methyl cap.
It sits over the methyl group
and protects it.
There needs to be a domain to
bind folic acid,
another domain binds
homocysteine,
and another domain over here
binds the S-adenosyl methionine
and is involved in that
oxidation-reduction reaction and
the remethylation.
What has to be true for this
enzyme is that you need at least
four different conformations.
You need a conformation where
the folic acid sits on top of a
B12.
It needs to give the methyl
group over.
You need a conformation where
the homocysteine in yellow
domain sits on top of the B12
and accepts the methyl group.
Zinc needs to be around there,
too.
You need a conformation that is
resting where the region that we
saw in the initial crystal
structure is sitting over this
cap.
It is capping the B12.
And you need a conformation
where this activating domain is
above the B12 to do the
oxidation-reduction reaction
there.
So we need at least these four
conformations.
And what is true is that the
enzyme is just kind of switching
conformation as it is going
through, and that these
conformations are in equilibrium
with each other and are just
shifting back and forth to these
different states.
And, when you add something
like folic acid,
it helps shift the conformation
to this form.
When you add homocysteine,
it helps shift the conformation
to this form.
This is just chemical
equilibrium going on.
There is a lot of things that
can be in equilibrium.
And enzyme conformations can be
in equilibrium,
just like some of the reactions
that we studied in the beginning
of the course.
Enzymes are dynamic.
Equilibrium is a dynamic
process.
Chemistry is dynamic.
Things are happening.
I am not talking about
chemistry in the solid state in
this course.
I am talking about chemistry in
solution, because that is
chemistry of life.
That is the chemistry that is
happening in your body that
allows you to breathe and live.
And so, finally,
I am going to show you
methionine synthase in action in
its dynamic process.